the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
all right my friends in this video we
will be discussing the one and only
daenerys of house targaryen our favorite
mother of dragons
now as you all know this character had
one of the most controversial endings in
television history
as a matter of fact the way this
character's story ended is a big reason
why game of thrones lost so many of its
fans around the globe
daenerys was and still is a beloved
character but over the span of the six
final episodes
dan and dave found a way to make her
look like an evil villain
her final acts in the series shocked
millions of fans
not only because what she had done but
mostly because of how it was handled
it basically felt like she went from a
good guy to a bad guy in the matter of
minutes
now there is a very good chance daenerys
could have this same exact ending in the
books
after everything that has happened to
this character over the years i don't
think it's that hard to believe she
could go in this direction in the end
the only issue is how it was done dany's
descent into madness should have
happened a bit more slower over the
final season
i think most of us would agree there
should have been more episodes
in fact there should have been more
seasons but i won't get into all of that
here
either way a lot of the fans were very
upset with how her character story ended
now she may never fully admit this
herself but i bet the actress amelia
does feel the same way
during a recent interview she did
finally reveal what scene she would
remove if she could
now actually think about all the
different scenes she was in
which one do you think it would be i'm
thinking most of you will
know exactly which one it is let me show
you what she said
was there any storyline or scene that i
would have changed
hmm right the bit where i died
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen if there is one scene amelia
clark could remove
it would be the scene where daenerys
targaryen died
now i'm sure some of you will think
she's only joking around because she was
laughing while she said it but i believe
she meant it as well
if you really want to know how this
actress felt about her final scenes go
back to the interview where she revealed
how she reacted after reading what would
eventually happen to her character
it's kind of heartbreaking actually let
me show you what she said about reading
her final scenes once she sat down with
entertainment weekly
it says emilia clarke read a paragraph
in the final script for game of thrones
she read it again and again seven times
she says
she read the words that revealed the
devastating fate of daenerys targaryen
a character she's portrayed on the hbo
global phenomenon for nearly a decade
what what what what the actress recalls
thinking
because it comes out of effing nowhere
i'm flabbergasted
absolutely never saw that coming once at
home the actress prepared herself
i got myself situated she says i got a
cup of tea
i had to physically prepare the space
and then begin reading them
as she flipped through the pages she saw
it said daenerys arrives at winterfell
and sansa doesn't like her
she discovers jon snow as the heir to
the iron throne and
isn't thrilled she fights in the battle
against the night king and survives
but loses a longtime friend sir jorah
mormont
then her other friend inadvisor
missandei dies too
varus betrays her jon snow backs away
having lost half her army a few dragons
and nearly everybody she cares about
daenerys goes full targaryen to win she
attacks king's landing and kills
thousands of civilians daenerys's
longtime conquest achieved
she meets with jon snow in the red keep
throne room and
and then then he i cried
amelia says and i went for a walk i
walked out of the house and grabbed my
keys and phone and walked back with
blisters on my feet
i didn't come back for five hours i'm
like how am i gonna do this
well i think this is a really good
indication of how she really felt about
the final season
have you shot your final scenes yet and
are you happy with how
things ended yeah
she didn't say yes you didn't say that
best season ever she more or less said
it herself
she was not expecting any of this to
happen to her character
now if you also hated dany's ending and
have wondered what would have happened
if her character did not die
i have a solution i will show you what
happens to daenerys if game of thrones
made a ninth season
now i'm sure most of you have already
been watching those videos but i know a
lot of you haven't
at the end of this video i will give you
a taste of what happens to daenerys
character
i will just show you what happens during
her resurrection and if you're
interested in watching more
and finding out what else happens with
her character then i will link the full
videos
in the right order down below if you're
not interested in watching that
then you can stop the video right here
the sun is just now beginning to set as
we see an even larger crowd
gather below the red temple of verlor
the streets of the city are now flooded
with thousands of followers of the lord
of light
drogon is sitting atop the building
overlooking everyone below
the dragon lets out another thunderous
scream
it's equally exciting and frightening
because everyone knows
they are witnessing a historic event the
high-ranking members of verlor
who are all still dressed in their red
robes are all gathered in a circle
around daenerys's body
they have her laid out across a stone
block in front of the massive brazier
they're all chanting something in high
valyria their chanting grows louder and
louder
as dark clouds begin to form in the sky
above
everyone in the crowd ducks down when
they hear an ear splitting crack of
thunder in the distance
violent flashes of lightning begin
emerging in the sky
the crowd below grows frantic as the
chanting gets louder
and the storm above grows stronger the
ruby necklace on kinvara's neck is
glowing
so red hot it starts burning the symbol
into her skin
a red bolt of lightning strikes down
into the middle of the brazier which
causes a small
fire to begin burning inside of it again
suddenly
the chanting stops all of the high
ranking members of relore
remove their hoods then they take a step
forward
all of them reach their hands under
daenerys's body
then lift her up into the sky they walk
over to the burning brazier
the crowd below erupts into chaos when
they realize what's about to happen
daenerys's lifeless body is thrown into
the flames
now all of the red robes gather in a
circle around the brazier
they remove their necklaces then throw
them inside
we watch as the rubies burst open into a
red liquid that almost looks like blood
fire and blood the small flames are now
several different shades of red
and orange kinvara looks up at drogon
her eyes are now glowing red as well in
a loud voice
kinvara shouts dracarus drogon spreads
his wings
and lets out another deafening scream
the fire unleashes from his mouth
into the brazier below there are men and
women in the crowd who are weeping with
joy
the flames reach high into the air as
they are licking at the night sky
the storm begins to settle as the clouds
begin to move
they reveal there was a full moon hiding
behind them
a blood moon everyone is now staring
into the fire
the reflection of the flames can be seen
in kinvara's glowing red eyes
everything is silent except for the
crackling of the fire
suddenly we hear the sound of thousands
gasping for air
as they see a black silhouette emerge in
the flames
as the fire dies down we can see a nude
body standing in the center of the
brazier
there is a large stab wound in their
chest there is some black smoke rising
out of it
the episode ends as daenerys emerges
through the flames in smoke
[Music]
um
[Music]
you